hey what's up my name's samuel and i'm
amanda and today we've been chilling at
the beach this is like our favorite part
of the world it really is we're
certainly in the uk where where are we
we're in sandbanks sandbanks beach so um
we're gonna show you around our
beautiful home we're renting this place
at the moment million pound home right
next to the beach we like it so much we
almost bought somewhere here we did we
were house shopping around here amanda
wouldn't let us buy what's the problem
with buying houses around here well
you've got the sea right here which i
love i know you love big flood risk
though yeah so risky in fact the
councillor are trying to enforce all
these beach houses to build a 27 foot
sea wall which is just gonna kill the
views i know kill the beach access so
we're not buying anywhere just yet we're
renting somewhere do you reckon i like
the house oh yeah you're gonna love it
keep watching three minute walk let's
take you around enjoy
that's that one that got sold for four
and a half million isn't it that's crazy
so basically
that house there
just sold for 4.5 million
clearly they ain't buying the house no
they're buying the location they're
buying the land yeah they're gonna knock
it down probably spend two three million
building a massive mansion and it's
gonna be worth stupid money but here's
the thing though imagine if you bought
that land that's what it is
yeah and then you have to build a 27
foot stable
27 that's higher than the great wall of
china it is it's it'll be like a prison
it'll be horrible right and then
suddenly you've got no beach access
you've got the house we're about to show
you which is literally a five minute
walk is well you'll find out the prices
but yeah way more sense oh definitely
crazy
this is the house here we are oh i love
this house
it's so lovely
you know what the location it's outside
of flood risk it's not home from home
it's very similar to our house it feels
like beckonsfield it's crazy yeah really
really nice what we'll do is we'll have
a quick look around the outside yeah and
then we'll go on in this place is lit
[Music]
if we bought this house which is a
possibility we haven't told the current
owner yet he doesn't know right now
we're just we're just renting it but if
we bought this house first thing i would
do you know what would i do first thing
what do you reckon
swim swimming pool right here yes right
here man swimming pool right here and
you can just feel the ocean breeze still
can't you i know yeah you can hear the
seagulls we're still so close yeah
so anyway that's where you drive in
nice entrance right there you can walk
around the entire house which we also
love so let's go around the inside
[Music]
come on in
welcome to my crib
we actually we're renting we're renting
this place right now and we're paying
like a nightly rate let's come on
through we'll talk about all the figures
how much everything costs
the great thing
about not owning the property is you can
just come in
you have to think about maintenance like
the gate was broken wasn't it yeah and
the landlord just fixed it of course but
how much how much did it cost us to just
fix our gate at home
oh my gosh we've just paid just over
five grand to have our gate rehome so
free hungry hung excuse me not even a
new guest i know not even
so it's crazy yeah so anyway do you like
this area i absolutely love this and
this kind of marble workshop is actually
what we're gonna have in our new kitchen
in beckensfield yeah um but i just love
this area even though it's much smaller
than our house it still feels big and
spacious and light and airy yeah and
yeah
the fact that you've got doors outside
it's very accessible you can literally
upstairs from the bedrooms you can see
the sea views which is amazing so we pay
per night to stay here we're currently
in peak season how much we pay right now
to stay here 500 pounds a night 500
pounds now you may be thinking why would
we pay 500 pounds to stay here when
we've already got home which is really
nice in beckham's field and the answer
is well we want the ocean we want to be
on the beach exactly
however um we're going to talk to you in
a moment about how much this house is
worth it'd be interesting if you guys
can guess how much it's worth because we
were shocked weren't we i know the
valuations how much this was bought for
how much it's worth now how much is
renting for so um anything else
downstairs you want to show i mean the
living room really cool nice
[Music]
i also love how they've got like all
this back
back lights going on like
this
stuff yeah it just feels very yeah very
really really nice the colors are nice i
like the yellow the gray
it pops yeah incredible
especially for sandbags because some of
the houses even like the mansions worth
like 10 20 million they're still kind of
on top of each other yeah because this
has got a bit of land around the side of
it which is really nice so um all right
so this house was last sold
so the person that owns it now bought it
for
do you remember uh
was it 962 000
almost okay 962 and 500 pounds five
hundred pounds yeah
that's less than a million pounds yeah i
know it's crazy absolutely crazy so this
was bought for less than a million
pounds in may 2017 down we could have
gone for less than a million however
interestingly you missed this
you missed this this house
was on the market for sale
a few months back but now the guy took
it off
so the landlord put it for sale
and took it off and it was on for sale
guide price of just 1.5 million no way
that's insane two views i know it's
insane because the house is on the beach
are literally like five six five six i
would probably rather live here you've
still got sea views let's go upstairs
we'll show you the sea views
so we've got four bedrooms they're all
good sized bedrooms yeah they are all
double one for each child and one for us
so let's go to the master bedroom first
with the sea views
so
oh this is it
it's so nice and scary biggest
juliet it's very i think there is a tv i
was talking about that we've not watched
this video yeah i know we haven't even
watched the tv yeah got too busy
watching that view sea views out here
mandy you were saying to me that the sea
views aren't proper see that they are
prophesied yeah they are i guess i guess
i'm thinking beach but this is more like
both this is the great thing about
sandbanks you've got like so we're on um
what's it what's the road called
panorama road panorama road so you've
got panorama road this side of the road
you've got the harbour and this side of
the road you've got the beach yeah with
the sea so it's like you've got water
everywhere yeah so yeah surrounded by
water they're all so friendly around
here aren't they yeah they are always
yeah the bathroom here is so nice
because though imagine being sat down on
the toilet
and having
[Music]
sunset beautiful nice bathroom
yeah really good
so this is the second room you've got an
ensuite once again so really great for
you know bigger families or if you've
got guests and stuff like that do you
think would you want to live here as
your main resident
not as my man why just because i think
that it's nice to have a space for the
kids like at home we've got that massive
room where they can just do whatever
they want yeah what about the area would
you live in science oh yeah of course
would you yeah is he not a bit far away
from stuff
well he's about two hours yeah but you
can live here like
some months of the year
[Laughter]
the rooms now get more and more
underwhelming smaller and smaller third
room
fourth room but the kids are getting
changed in there so i'll block this room
and um that's it it's not actually that
big is it no it's not it looks a lot
bigger from the outside yeah it does but
it's modern it's beautiful it's next to
the beach the question is 1.5 million
would you buy it
yes would you do you think there'd be
better options around here
i don't know babe because i think for
1.5 you literally five minutes walk from
the beach yeah the beach property do you
want to message the landlord and make
him an offer then
well hear her why not what do you think
guys comment below what are your
thoughts do you like the house
do you think it's worth 1.5 million or
would you rather buy on the beach and
pay 10 million and have a 27 meter wall
outside and flood risk with no insurance
let us know in the comments
you